aujourd'hui on va poursuivre de façon à
répertorier toutes les épaves aussi qui
sont à terre sur la déchéance de
propriété sur des propriétaires qui ont
abandonné leurs bateaux donc les
services de l'état vont donner
d'échéance de propriété de façon à
pouvoir évacuer ces épaves et ensuite
nous allons passer à une dépollution
sous marine nous allons de répertorier
tous ceux qui donc objet ne bâtit tout
ce qui est objet sous l'eau identifié
par les associations et ensuite que nous
allons faire est venue alors que ça va
prendre
aujourd'hui nous sommes à une opération
qui a fait une cinquantaine de tonnes de
déchets une quarantaine de tonnes du pav
tous nous allons tout de 800 millions et
nous allons en pas la suite continuer à
faire tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
que ceux-ci toit d'autres ouvrent ses
lettres de noblesse